so here's where we're going to begin the
first of subheading is called addition
and subtraction of coordinates most of
you probably have not heard of the use
of the word ordinates in that singular
way we don't usually talk about
ordinates we usually talk about
coordinates right we've got a pair of
these okay this is a bit funny really
I haven't reconcile this but if you have
one and three okay so we call this as a
pin coordinates right Khomeni together
and mordents meet is two of them okay
however the technical name for these two
things are the x-coordinate is actually
give this weird a which you never ever
hear and almost no one talks about it's
called and sister I don't know what it
means yet but you can look it up if you
like that's what's actually called and
it's gonna be here though why that's
actually cool it just by itself a little
bit okay tell me buddy get in the door
for me no I think will do okay so when
they talk about addition and subtraction
of modernist they mean it in this
specific way they're talking about they
talk about y-values they're talking to
help high up or down you are okay now we
can craft any function that is the sum
or difference of two other functions by
taking all of the ornaments on a
y-coordinate adding or subtracting them
so let me give you an example of what
you actually could draw without this
method so you know what to expect you
can give this to go well we're gonna
start with
okay yeah y equals x plus whatever X
okay
you actually know a plenty to graph this
through that this method I'm going to
show you okay but eventually it's gonna
happen is this method is all you're
going to be able to use it to graph some
of the other things that I'm going to
demonstrate okay now just before we go
if I go ahead if I were to graph this
like I just told you right now go ahead
and graph it what would you do this you
probably put it together this right and
then what conclusions would you drop
okay
can you uh you can you can say well I'm
actually gonna go back a standard can I
factorize this and the answer is no and
that's why the next step which is
asymptotes okay so I can see it's going
to have an asymptote x equals zero right
so there's that vertical would I'm going
to have as it turns out we have an
oblique asymptote they don't tell why
yeah look at the degree on time right
the degree is higher than the degree
here so as X gets very large positive
and very very large negative okay this
guy's gonna grow he's gonna grow out of
control in comparison to this guy you
can look at intercepts right are they
going to be any intercepts that I can
talk about I know I know already I'm not
gonna get any y intercepts because I
can't let X equal zero right and it
doesn't take me that much long to
realize I'm not gonna get any
x-intercepts either
why not
okay see ya
we have language for this by the way
this is a quadratic we would call it
positive definite right so B but it's
never ever going to touch the axes the
whole thing is never gonna touch the
axis okay now you're starting to get a
picture of this and in fact from
therefore all of the discussion we just
had you could draw a picture but this
method takes us back to here and says
okay if that's all we know can we draw
this too so on a set of axes what I
would like you to do that again I keep
on saying is if you have another color
this will be enormous like helpful if
you do not you're just gonna have to
either do so what sort of feathering of
your graph so you can tell these things
apart or you're going to have to like
drop things around
be careful cuz you gonna have asymptotes
sorry here's what we going to do to
graph the whole thing I'm going to graph
its component parts and then I'm gonna
go look at the order that's the Y values
now I'm going to add them up as I go
that's gonna be my approached okay so y
equals x and y equals 1 over X let's
graph them on and like I said yellow
color he's knows